[Music]
here with a special announcement about
some new categories
kristen wick hi hi hi everyone hi
hi grandpa hi little kid i'm just
kidding no one's here
so usually this is the part of the show
where the president of the awards comes
out and talks about how the awards are
different this year
and kills all the fun momentum everyone
built throughout the night with a boring
speech
but we're not doing that no instead
they asked me kristin bartholomew wig
just kidding that's not my middle name
to share with you this big change this
year
for the first time in history the spirit
awards will be honoring the best in
independent television but what exactly
is an
independent tv show i'm gonna tell you
step one what's the vibe
as we all know the independent and
independent film
mainly just refers to a general
cheapness in the budget and overall fill
the same is also true for television if
something left you feeling more sad
than happy that's the indie baby
especially if it's a comedy which brings
us to step two
is it popular i surveyed some random
people
folks that tragically live somewhere
between new york and la
people with actual jobs and anyone who
has ever been to
an imagine dragons concert and i ran
some shows by them
and if they hadn't heard the show i sat
with them and made them watch every
single episode
i'm just kidding i don't have time for
that if they hadn't heard the show it
went to the top of the list
lastly our third and least important
step step three
it had to come out within the last year
that last one is pretty
self-explanatory but i must explain it
anyway
i guess i just did i'm so funny
the independent spirit awards now
officially cover tv
and still cover film yay
i could dance right now but i'm not
because i'm gonna go shoot
my new movie barb and star live in their
car
and hope it's nominated for best feature
next
yar i love to rhyme oh i love to rhyme
bye